jakob wie sie die perfekte model für
dich aus
gute frage rudern nur ein gewand nudel
aber nicht zu lang wird also noch mal
auf eine gabel kriegt sie kann so
aufnehmen sie kann
sehr sehr viel soße aufnehmen
das ist keine frage okay zugegeben das
ist eine sehr komische frage die einfach
so zu stellen aber ich habe letztens
etwas sehr spannendes entdeckt angeblich
hat jemand die perfekte nudel erfunden
und zwar durch seien er sei es aber was
machen andere nudeln eigentlich so
falsch wie fasst man wissenschaftlich
zusammen was eine perfekte nudel
ausmacht und warum kommt am ende dabei
so ein komischer einigen tentakel heraus
die einzig logische konsequenz um all
das zu beantworten ist wir haben uns
kiloweise nudeln ins büro bestellt und
eine pasta party geschmissen
[Musik]
und boris
spaghetti sind schlechte nudeln da ich
habe es gesagt pasta e basta bevor ich
mich jetzt unbeliebt mache das ist
natürlich nicht meine worte sondern die
des erfinders der angeblich perfekten
nudel um zu verstehen was eine nudel
perfekt machen kann muss man aber auch
erst einmal verstehen was andere nudeln
nicht perfekt machen deswegen ruft schon
mal die pasta police an ich muss jetzt
einmal ganz kurz eure nudel gefühle
verletzen
[Applaus]
die erfinder der perfekten nudel
beschreiben das alles so spaghetti die
sind außen sehr glatt unterhält die soße
nur schwierig dran und das gleiche
problem haben auch linguine deswegen
sind das schon eine nicht perfekte
nudeln okay daneben bugatti nie das ist
quasi das uneheliche kind von makkaroni
und spaghetti das heißt durch die ganze
nudel zieht sich ein kanal um die soße
in der nudel zu speichern und im
gegensatz zu doktor watson könnt ihr
diesen kanal leider nicht abonnieren
aber auch platini italienische
strohhalme sind nicht der heilige gral
wenn man die nudel götter fragt soße ist
meistens zu dick um die nudel kanal zu
durchdringen ähnlich übrigens wie bei
makkaroni dazu kommt dass es einfach ein
albtraum ist bugatti mir auf die gabel
zu bekommen
[Musik]
ok dann probieren wir mal von langen
dünnen zu kurzen und dicken nudeln zu
kommen im gegensatz zu bugatti ist das
loch in rigatoni groß genug um soße zu
speichern dazu kommt dass die außenseite
nicht glatt ist sondern so rillen hat an
der sich die soße festhalten kann auf
jeden fall ein pluspunkt und die nudel
ist auch im gegensatz zu zb angel her
angenehm dick sie hat bis sind rigatoni
also perfekt leider nein denn auch bei
regazzoni ist nicht alles gold was
glänzt das loch in der mitte ist zum
beispiel zu groß um es mit der gabel
komplett zu durchstoßen perfekt klappt
das bei falle aber jeder der schon mal
verfalle gekocht hat weiß die kriegt man
eigentlich nicht richtig gar entweder
sind die flügel außen zu weich und
labbrig oder genau richtig aber dann ist
der ganze tag in der mitte noch halb roh
al dente sucht man hier vergeblich okay
okay ich glaube ich habe genug um
genügend wie kommt man also von den
ganzen fehlern der 130 nudelsorten zu
wissenschaftlichen kriterien für die
eine perfekte model kurz gesagt was sind
die maßstäbe die wir an eine nudel haben
sollten
genau darauf geben die erfinder in ihrem
podcast ausführlich antwort für sie gibt
es drei wichtige kriterien erstens
vorgebildet ii also zu deutsch gabe
lichkeit wie gut kann ich meine gabel in
die pasta stecken aber auch drin
behalten wenn die nudel auf dem weg zu
meinem mund ist die folge bildet in der
liga toni nudel ist zum beispiel sagen
wir mal ziemlich ausbaufähig meine gabel
schafft es vielleicht durch die erste
wand aber nicht auf der anderen seite
wieder heraus auf dem weg zum und kann
so die so sehr herr ausfallen oder sogar
noch schlimmeres passieren
zweitens ist die saw the ballad ii also
die so sich kite wie gut ist die nun in
der lage soße aufzunehmen und zu
behalten um bei der mediatorin zu
bleiben die nehmen so super auf
spaghetti linguine oder bugatti hingegen
nicht so sehr denn sie haben ja keine
oberfläche an der sich die soße
festhalten kann oder ein loch das groß
genug ist um die soße zu speichern und
der dritte wichtige punkt den die
perfekte model haben sollte ist to think
pille team die beschreibt wie
befriedigend es ist die szene in der
nudel zu versenken angel her also
richtig richtig dünne spaghetti haben
zum beispiel fast keinen biss hier muss
ich mir beinahe astronomische mengen um
die gabel wickeln um was zum kauen zu
haben aber augen auf bei der pasta
selektion mehr teig heißt nicht gleich
gute to think gebildete beliebter fehler
verfallen stehen am anderen ende des
spektrums wie schon erwähnt ist hier in
der mitte super viel teig das verspricht
natürlich ein gutes gefühl aber wenn die
nudel dafür ungleich gar wird dann ist
der passat spaß auch wieder ganz schnell
vorbei ihr seht das ist alles wirklich
nicht einfach ok halten wir mal fest die
drei kriterien sind frauke thies of the
ability und tief sinken und bisher gab
es laut dem selbsternannten der finder
der perfekten nudel keine einzige
nudelsorten die alle drei kriterien
befriedigend erfüllt
bis jetzt
ok irgendwie sieht das ja schon ganz
schön seltsam aus mich hat das
allererste moment tatsächlich an alien
tentakel erinnert das wisst ihr was ich
meine und tatsächlich ist natürlich kein
appetitlicher name für eine nudel alien
tentakel linie deswegen hat man sie
achtung gas kartell liegen land das
capelli das kartell das leite sich vom
italienischen wort kaska also wasserfall
ab klingt cool ist allerdings
grammatikalisch kompletter quatsch und
überhaupt kein richtiges installieren
ist aber das trifft zugegebenermaßen auf
die nudel selber zu denn die kommt auch
nicht aus dem land des großen stiefels
aber wie sagt man noch als altes
sprichwort mailand madrid oder
massachusetts egal hauptsache italien
bon appétit das kartell ii kommen aus
den vereinigten staaten und die
entwicklung läuft schon seit 2008 10
seit diesem jahr kann man die nudel auch
kaufen und bisher scheint sich das mega
zu lohnen denn sie sind überall
ausverkauft vor redaktionsschluss hat
das stolze zehn wochen gedauert bis wir
eine packung der begehrten kohlenhydrate
torpedos bekommen haben und jetzt wollen
wir mal testen ob diese lügen
tatsächlich ihre wartezeit wert sind
[Musik]
sehr viel bis die sauce war sehr
gleichmäßig da drin so bissfestigkeit
war sehr gut besser als bei den
spaghetti tatsächlich und sie waren
einfacher zu essen schön fest abstimmen
an dieser stelle ist es mir sehr wichtig
zu erwähnen dass das hier keine werbung
ist wir kriegen kein geld da für diese
passt irgendwie zu regionen unser pastor
journalismus ist unabhängig also sind
das die perfekten hartweizen saucen
transportvehikel oder ist das alles
unnötiger quatsch gut meine meinung
casartelli sind wirklich lecker und
tatsächlich sammelt sich die soße darin
richtig gut ich würde fast sagen dass
sie so wie tortellini schmecken also so
wie gefüllte nudeln nur mit dem
unterschied dass sich die nudeln durch
ihre form selber mit so vielen was
ziemlich cool ist aber
selbstverständlich sind nudeln nicht nur
wissenschaft nicht nur zahlen und cinque
bildet ihr spaghetti auch wenn die von
den erfindern ganz schön viel kritik
bekommen sind meiner meinung nach sehr
neiße nudeln und ja irgendwie auch ein
erlebnis die nudeln einzusaugen auch
wenn es dem geschmack nicht wirklich
hilft ist ein großer teil der spaghetti
erfahrung essen hat eben auch einen
riesigen emotionalen wert spaghetti ist
die erste pasta die viele in ihrer
kindheit gegessen haben und natürlich
hängen da viele schöne
kindheitserinnerungen daran kann man das
wissenschaftlich messen wahrscheinlich
nicht kurzum casartelli sind gute mögen
vielleicht sogar sehr gute nudeln und
sie schmecken so als hätte man sich
wirklich gedanken gemacht trotzdem denke
ich nicht dass sie alle anderen pasta
sorten jetzt vom thron schmeißen werden
und es muss auch gar nicht sein wie auch
bei autos kameras und smartphones gilt
es gibt nicht das eine beste sondern
maximal dass eine beste für einen
bestimmten zweck und abwechslung ist
sowieso immer gut deswegen vergesst
nicht den kanal hin zu abonnieren
vergiss nicht alle anderen science
kanäle zu abonnieren für die abwechslung
und bleibt wie immer hungrig
[Musik]
al dente
ist für mich auch
total schief think blue sea sehr
schwierig auszusprechen begriff